As we go to our next game,
2 in the Walls, 8 in the Balls.
Etsy finally has found
a solution to all those times
you've been shoving things
in your ass while wondering
what lies ahead in your future,
a Magic 8-Ball plug.
-Oh. "Reply hazy,
ass again later." -Hey!
This item is listed on Etsy
for a surprisingly
reasonable price of 30 bucks.
-30 U.S. dollars.
-That's not...
-You can't get a butt plug
that cheap, man. -No!
Like, it sucks that the future's
attached to it, but still.
One has to wonder
what fortunes will be told
on the Magic 8-Ball
that powers your ass.
I would like you to come up
with as many Magic 8-Ball
butt plug fortunes
as you can in 60 seconds.
Please begin. Matt Mira.
Moist likely.
Points. Brian Posehn.
Outlook foggy.
Nope, that's just (bleep).
Poi... Points.
Points. Brian Posehn.
Your future stinks.
Points. Brian Posehn again.
-It's a living!
-Points, yes.
-With the Flintstones, it would
be, like, a lizard -Yeah.
on the back of a stick.
Yeah. Points. Matt Mira.
If you're sliding into first
and you feel something burst...
it is certain.
Points.
Well-well played. Kevin.
Can't see. Poo over.
Points. Matt Mira.
My reply is yeah!